alex like everybody else in the world
had heard a lot of hype around
blockchain and cryptocurrency being a
techie he started exploring blockchain
and cryptocurrency and understood that
blockchain is a distributed digital
database that makes recording
transactions and managing assets in a
corporate network much easier and a
cryptocurrency on the other hand is a
digital currency that acts as a medium
of exchange over a blockchain network it
is not supported by any central
authority such as a government or bank
but what intrigued him was how people
contribute to blockchain so he decided
to go to a friend sarah who is a
blockchain expert upon asking how people
actually participate in blockchain sarah
answered this occurs via crypto mining
cryptocurrency mining is the process by
which specialized computers often known
as nodes or mining rigs validate
blockchain transactions for a specific
crypto coin in exchange for a mining
payout listening to this alex asked if
he could also join this network and be a
part of the crypto mining process sarah
said it's a little difficult because
crypto mining requires a huge setup like
a high-end processor gpu high
performance graphics card lots of
electricity and an ac and to set up all
this he needs a huge amount of land alex
was disappointed and that is when sarah
said but there is one network that you
can mine without any hassle it is pi
network alex got curious and asked what
pi network is and how it can act
differently from other cryptocurrencies
sarah explained that pi network is a
digital currency initiative that
attempts to make cryptocurrency mining
accessible as first-generation
currencies such as bitcoin have become
too centralized for many daily users
let's understand this in detail pi
network came into the picture in 2019
itself since then it has been in testing
mode even though it's not launched yet
it still offers to mine its coins and
here's how to mine it users must first
safeguard the currency they also need to
expand their network by referring it to
others all you need to do is one every
day log in and click a button to receive
digital cash there is no evidence of
labor being done they simply log in and
press a button because this currency is
not yet exchanged it has no value two
increase your level by inviting
additional people to the site this
allows them to accumulate more digital
cash each day in pyramid schemes and
multi-level marketing this is a common
model she further added that pi was
designed to be halved regularly to
protect its scarcity when a miner
receives half as many coins for
processing new transactions this is
known as having it usually happens when
you reach a certain milestone when pi
hit 100 000 users its mining rate fell
to 1.6 per hour then to 0.4 per hour
then to 0.2 per hour and finally to 0.2
per hour when it reached 10 million
users it will continue to have until 1
billion users are reached on learning
about this whole new cryptocurrency
transformation in pi network alex was
sure that he definitely wanted to lay
his hands on it for once with branding
based on the number pi the project's
first phase began on pi day on march 14
2019 with the free pie mining app the
network had over 100 000 active users by
june 2019 when phase 2 began a year
later more than 3.5 million users were
there in may 2020 the app began running
advertisements in order to raise funds
for the project on march 15 2022 pi
network said its user base had grown to
33 million up from 14 million in march
2021
so here's a question for you what makes
pi crypto unique
a decentralized nature b having method c
status as social currency d huge
circulation volume please take a minute
to think about it and leave your answers
in the comments section below three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers experts believe that pi
cryptocurrency will have a lesser value
versus the us dollar than other digital
coin debuts they further claim that as
the pi network's adoption grows it has
unlimited growth potential it also
predicts that by 2025 the price of a pie
coin might reach five dollars the pie
network's validity and utility to users
will only be determined after its
introduction however numerous exchange
sites have predicted that pai has a
bright future we hope you enjoyed this
video if you did a thumbs up would be
really appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]